c'est à côté de lure à la côte 518
habitants que jacqueline gourault
découvre la haute saône par son
industrie à la campagne dans cette
entreprise on fabrique des balayeuses
notamment pour la ville de paris une
mise en avant du savoir-faire haut
saônois on a des talents
il faut les valoriser qu'ils soient
industriels nos talents aussi d'élus
locaux qui ont le coeur à l'ouvragé qui
ont besoin d'être entendus c'était
l'objectif ce matin la cohésion des
territoires c'est le portefeuille de
jacqueline gourault et c'est à ce titre
que la ministre était très attendue
allure pour évoquer l'abandon du dossier
de la prison et les conséquences pour
une ville qui se sont déjà malmené par
un autre abandon celui de différents
services publics
un tour de table des échanges et des
annonces dont un renforcement de l'aide
de l'état dans les projets sur le bassin
lurons mais rien ne concernant la prison
l'hôpital de lure serait un hôpital
labellisé hôpital de proximité est par
ailleurs aussi un projet que le travail
le préfet à savoir vis fiscaux
c'est-à-dire une vingtaine de postes qui
seraient créés allure alors allure on
prend acte de ces annonces tout en
regrettant justement l'absence des
changes sur le dossier de la prison la
mise et territoires dont ce n'est pas la
prérogative
la délégation a confirmé la décision de
sa collègue mme belloubet de ne pas
implanter une maison d'arrêt allure
je conteste cette décision tout ça pour
ça quoi ça valait pas grand chose mais
là on a vraiment pas grand chose il ya
quelques petites choses au saupoudrage
pour les élus dossier si quelques postes
dans le domaine financier là une visite
et des engagements qui n'ont pas
forcément convaincu les principaux
acteurs du territoire de lure et le
maire de la commune nous a dit tout à
l'heure que concernant le dossier de la
prison et ne lâchera rien le 3 avril
prochain il ira rencontrer des
conseillers du premier ministre à
matignon